Vậy phẩm phần chai cô cũng tích tục mang lại nghiêm tự hào cho chất lượng của giám vận tụi Việt Nam khi có bố giá mắt tại pháp và các cơ có ra đi mình chỗ ông.
Cô mốt này được đánh dòng qua sự kiện kiết giám mắt cô cũng tại tỷ trường phác sĩnh giá và gối thup ba năm nay,
cô không chính thức bắt tay cùng nhà phân phối Mỹ phẩm duy tính tại chỗ ông, Orion J.
sự hợp tâm này được đánh dá không chỉ đến thần là một dòng tỷ trường.
Nếu còn nămu dấu mốt được liệt khi một tụi Việt phẩm thần chai được viên kiểu và sản xuất tại Việt Nam,
cô cộng bộ pháp một trong những chung tâm làm đề quan trọng của thế giới.
Theo chiếc sẻ từ đại dự hưởng, hàng trình đến với nước pháp mắt luôn hai năm để hoàn hiện hủ sư và đáp ứng các vi định nghiêm hạt của thế trường chỗ ông.
Lượng nhất các tự trường của bản định ra nhập vào các thị trường này bao gồm,
đưa trường thực hành sản xuất bố G&P tại nhà máy, đang kí trên cộng thủ báo Mỹ phẩm chỗ ông, CPNP,
thân tụi các vi định về hướng đều thật thư trường của hiệu bộ hiệu bộ hiệu bộ hiệu bộ hiệu phẩm của thế,
ai NCI cũng có yêu cầu pháp liền tại chỗ ông, năm trong chủi choi hỏi động trọng sinh tại pháp và khách thị trường tại chỗ ông,
ngày 12 thử cộng đặc hai chương công dân trại hiện 1 sáng xử phẩm, có pháp cáp stock,
lâu thiên tại chỗ Đô Paris, hỏi động đã tụi sức thăm xác của đồng đảo với hàng tại đây.
Dưới lòng Paris cộng tại hiện 1 có quen thuộc của Việt Nam, CPNP,
1 không xanh bộm mặc hình dầu tính kết nối, nên mọi người có thể gọi lại gần nhau hơn,
trọng giải thử tức liền cơ phê đặc lắt đợt là sẽ chia nha có chuyện không buổi vạm và tận lượng cảm giác hiện diện trọng thệ trong kia dưới thử.
Ông pháp minh giung, giá đốc kinh dân và tất hiện của cô cùng chiếc sẻ nơi đây không chỉ giới thiệu cô chuyện làm đẹp lành tính,
hếu quả tư núc sản đặc hiệu lúc ta mà còn mang theo hơi thử một Việt Nam mình dị,
dú mặt bệ phúc tế hiệu hơn về văn hóa, con người Việt.
Lên mình cho ông nói chung và pháp mọi diện được xem những chung tâm lâu đời với có ai đủ lớn của người nghĩ phần tòa cầu.
U sa này xử dụng nhiều tập bàn đàn đẹp lưỡn và hệ dự thái hiện kiểu, sản xuất phát triển đong phai trọng quan trọng việc định nghiên cứu trận chất lượng,
an toàn và suy bữ từ dùng tại cho ông.
Bây cô không hiện diện các khí trường khó tính như pháp trọng thệ suy bương mối của người đàn đẹp Việt Nam.